hi my name's jim gaffigan i play lucas
dad lorenzo
my name is maya rudolph and i play
luca's mom daniela
my name is emma berman and i play julia
marco valdo
my name is jacqueline grazer and i play
alberto my name is jacob tremblay and i
play luca
in the pixar and disney film luca and
today we're going to see which luca
character we truly are there's no
winning though it's just
of course there is okay whoever gets
luca wins i know i'm gonna get samantha
from sex in the city
first what is your greatest strength i'm
passionate i'm a natural born leader
i'm adventurous i'm a problem solver i
can keep any secret or i'm organized
i would say i'm pretty passionate i'm
going to go without the bottom three
it's nice there's a lot of passionate
people here i'd say that i'm adventurous
all right i'm going problem solver we
needed a problem solver in this group
pick a water activity kayaking fishing
sailing surfing
scuba diving or swimming i wish there
was a drinking water
activity i'm gonna go with kayaking
because i do a lot of that i'd go scuba
diving because maybe i'd meet luca
that'd be fun for a second i was like
well i like to eat fish
i'll go with surfing the fishing thing
it seems the most
passive of all these so i'm gonna pick i
feel like that's a
i feel like that's a trick question i
don't think anyone should go with
fishing for this
movie i don't think that yeah that means
you're like the bad guy
i would always think of you as a sailor
jim thank you but you know i also
feel like i want to be honest here right
i don't want to lie
you can say something out loud but then
press a different button and we'll never
know
i'm not going to tell you it's private
i'm going to go swimming guys
i'm pretty cool what color vegetable
would you want to have
red purple green pink black or silver i
already know the answer to this and
i want to stream purple i wanted to be
that like pistachio green
yeah i'd go with that too i don't want
it to be silver i'm not a hot rod
the weird thing is is i am a hot rod
i think pink is the obvious answer so
i'd like a true champ
emma's definitely gonna win guys i gotta
break it too
what would you do with your porteroso
cup winnings
split it with your friends and family
buy your dream car
travel the world attend any college
open a restaurant or save it all for
later attend the college of my dreams
what are you kidding no
i'm saving it for later i'm definitely
trapped i think i'm gonna travel with
you let's travel
yeah let's do it i'm in first class
you're in coach though i'll buy my own
tickets what's the issue
choose a coffee dish penne el pesto
spaghetti and meatballs
lasagna penne vodka ravioli
fettuccine alfredo oh my god vodka pasta
is so good
i also love a fresh ravioli just like a
little baby pillow
this is such an important question
because all is just so delicious
again it's a trick question this whole
thing is a question i'm gonna go with
the penne though
smart chocolate i'm gonna go with the
pesto i'm gonna go with ravioli and hope
that it's mushroom flavored
okay i wanna know what y'all would say
is your least favorite one out of these
this is a very unpopular opinion and you
guys might bash me for this but i have
to say lasagna
okay i agree lasagna knocks you out it's
just too heavy
when you eat the pasta with your hands
in the movie that made me want to eat
pots with my hands cartoon food always
looks so much better than real food
pick a place to visit in italy rome
venice
milan amalfi coast florence or tuscany
i'm gonna go with her baby i'm off
because the mafia coast is a dream and
you could just eat fresh fish
and it's like heaven on earth that
sounds like a dream like the best dream
you've ever had in your life so i'm
definitely going there
i'm just picking around because i just
want to fight like a gladiator
i'm going tuscany because that that
looks very relaxing and finally
choose a pixar movie to watch up soul
toy story the incredibles inside out or
coco
i just saw seoul i just went with
incredibles again
my kids just watched coco again i watch
toy story
all the time with them i'm going to go
with up that yeah
i'm still looking for the all of the
above
i got julia but i'm very happy with that
answer wow
personality matches julia you are
energetic determined and smart like
julia once you set your mind to
something
you're determined to see it through to
the end i like that
that's good i got your character
your personality matches alberto you are
adventurous
brave and charismatic you are someone
who will do anything to protect your
friends
even if it means causing a little
trouble yeah that's why i also got all
birthday too
i got alberto too i got luba guys i got
luca
prince your personality matches luka
you're kind intelligent and sincere
like luca you want to explore the world
and learn as much as possible
while you can be a little hesitant to
try new things once you do there's
nothing that'll stop you from having the
time of your life
i knew i won i should get your face on
all the billboards now
[Music]
you